um
mike look who's back
number was number 14 trending yesterday
on youtube jablinski games
i'm not number 14
trending yesterday not a joke skippity
woo
let's let's do a refresher you're
getting happy about this anymore 3.5
million views
here we go
[Music]
i know people that don't even play drums
they could do that yeah that's like the
literally what everybody does when you
play the
dude
anybody can sit down and do that at a
[ __ ] guitar center
so mike he made a new video i hate this
man
this went from like i would have [ __ ]
tool to just i hate this man
do you know how much money because i i
would check the social blade do you know
how much money he made with the first
three videos
because you know gives you an estimate
about how much money he's making i'm
gonna
first three videos just just remember
these videos are two minutes long
186 thousand dollars
but this is what's that from socialblade
right so so it's at anywhere between you
know there to there so we'll call it 100
because it's way off but
that's that's enraging
like i'd be a couple grand whatever oh
that makes me so mad
but he needs some money does he does he
need the money
still getting orange county residuals
black need the money
um so here we go gablin's jabils
[Applause]
it's me jack black here no video gaming
this week unfortunately still
get the bit do you get the bit he's
never going to play video games
get out the elgato but it's coming soon
figure that out on the first episode
rice
yeah uh also something remember
this is a game that you could play i
mean if you're at work i wouldn't
recommend it unless you want to say [ __ ]
it dude
but uh you could take a shot
or drink every time he does a funny
voice or sings
so this is a two minute video let's see
240 matt 249
figured out the elgato but it's coming
soon and it is going to whoop
ass but i do want you to check out a
couple things
check this out rocking and rolling like
jack black schooling you [ __ ] like
jack black
how could you not like jack black i put
that on my mama [ __ ] no cat
ammone are you kidding me school of
rap that is beautiful this is ammone get
it
yeah yeah because this is the anime i
got it
so good at this take a shot he's
timeless beautiful
i need to see this movie no he's more
like priceless which because he's
worthless
worth not literally worthless worthless
oh sorry he's about to do a funny voice
i apologize i didn't mean to take that
away from you
i need to see this movie dude i was
touched
seriously blackjack school of rap
let's do this a lot of people don't know
this but
i uh i'm not just a rocker i'm also a
rapper
get ready for wackiness get ready for
wackiness
why do you do this here comes the wacky
why do you do this to me
all the ladies in the house say yeah
yeah come on your mother father
[Laughter]
you know what time it is
not saying [ __ ] because you
don't want to get demonetized
who is watching this
um i would say aging limp bizkit fans
this is making me angry who's why is
this a thing why is this trendy
it was number 14 trending yesterday it's
still number 35
trending yeah
it's tenacious d time your mother father
go
you guys drunk yet nobody knows who
tenacious d is in 2019.
oh don't worry there's a clip oh and uh
speaking of tenacious d
check this out
whoa old men dancing what crazy is this
this is nuts this guy's hilarious dude
that was me and my partner in crime kg
of tenacious d
as you can see we still got it we still
got the movie gee
[ __ ] posting no he's legit
he's not like he thinks this is good
well i mean mike i'll have you know that
320 thousand 300 320
000 people think he's good i will gain
jack black's respect if he comes out
in a month and goes i did that as a [ __ ]
look those are the worst videos ever and
you idiots
you guys kept watching just kept
uploading them and giving me money
oh and also i started a new band with
james hetfield
[Applause]
i would have if that happened at
metallica concert
i would go right to the box office and
go i want my money right now
yes and you're paying for my uber home i
didn't pay 160 dollars
for [ __ ] for general admission to see
metallica to see
jack black sing the bridge of one thank
you
oh but you know what also we could still
do a little gaming
uh let me just show you a little
something it's my favorite pinball
machine of all time
i would rather this channel be called
jabin chubalinsky
you're right about town he's doing a
funny voice ready pinball machine of all
times
darcy blows the addams family
the greatest pinball machine didn't he
already do a pinball episode i'm doing
i'm going to do it my own parody now
it's more shinsky i like it and i'm
going to do like all these short videos
out and about and be like hey what's
merce maple and mabel's what's
merchanting mercers
and i'll be like hey sorry guys no
tonight
yeah we're just gonna higher else yeah
so just go around just hanging out with
people
when's the what's gonna happen i wanna
see the
old times designed by the great pat
lawler greatest pinball designer of all
time this is what the kids like
i wish that this video would end
uh i wish this pinball machine would end
the way al duke's pinball machine
ended back in the ronin op anthony days
uh when when uh for those of you not
that don't know the opie and anthony
lore
uh producer al dukes pissed off uh
op years ago and presented him with a
pinball machine as a gift
to make amends and opie smashed the
pinball machine
remember that yes what a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
i hope this sounds like it did with jody
foster in a pinball machine
[Laughter]
the great raul julia and angelica
houston
in this timeless classic 1991
a very good year for pinball
yet another thrilling episode of
jablinski grahams
that's a funny voice that's a really
funny voice i swear to god man if this
if this were a different time this were
a different era in this country i would
just kidding though you're not getting
them back till you stop this trash dove
no jodie foster jokes
you got here late i already made it
catch you on football
see you next week this is jim edward
what the [ __ ] i love funny voices
this is what
we should have never let this become
famous this this is
you know it's it's it's collectively all
on us no this is our fault it's our
generation's fault
we we let this happen i want to
apologize for jack black look he was
good in orange county
yes very funny in that and then he was
in like one more that was like
what was the other one that he was a
right in this did the same gimmick but
it was kind of funny
and then he just blew up it couldn't be
helped
i'm trying to think of that other what
other movie am i oh uh
no that was man it's really hard to
think of a good jack black movie now
because he's had so many
bad ones if i was going to orange county
that's the one that i just that's the
one you're right
that's the one i remember all right i'm
looking i'm looking up
uh jack black right now just to see if
there's if there's anything maybe i
missed
but uh i don't think so what's the list
of jax black's greatest hits
there was the one where bruce will to
jackal where bruce willis killed him
with a gun remember that
was it bruce willis the jackal was that
was yeah he was in it he was when they
got shot with a powerful gun i believe
he was in the movie the fan who was he
random fan one broadcast technician he
played broadband
i know he was in shallow hell uh using
dead man walking
uh um he wasn't the cable guy but he had
a really smart
small part year one i guess he was he
wasn't demolition man
i do remember that i just looked at it
and i was like he wasn't that
yeah i guess yeah you're right uh okay i
will say this
he was in the film the great the great
american film
uh airborne her airborne
you know wearing a skateboard movie
airborne no oh you don't remember
airborne
oh it's so bad came out when i was like
10.
it was for 10 years yeah it was the
coolest movie ever when i was like you
know 10 or 11.
he was also was he in saving silverman i
think maybe uh
anyway press one in the chat if you
remember airborne